Okay, on your site, you advise fasting prior to having chemotherapy administered certain
chemo, such as full-fox, required fusions that go across the period of 48 hours.
What do you recommend, what do you recommend, recommendations for fasting given that treatment?
Also, when I asked the clinic advised against fasting, as in lower blood sugars, it may
result in nausea during treatment.
Well, there's multiple studies of fasting in chemotherapy, and one of them, one of them
tested people fasting for 48 hours prior to the chemotherapy infusion, and another
fasted for 24 hours prior to the chemotherapy infusion.
And I know there's other practitioners that ask people to fast 24 hours before their infusion
in 24 hours after the initial intake of the infusion, so you wouldn't need to tell
you got home maybe 18 hours after you got home.
I've always asked people to cut it in the middle and just do a 24 hour fast prior to the
chemotherapy infusion and eat when you get home.
Now if you're doing the chemotherapy, the whole idea of that basically is to lower your blood
sugar before you do chemotherapy.
Basically, if you could think of it as a cartoon, the cancer cells are much hungrier than
your regular cells because they're more metabolically active.
Because they're in a state of rapid replication, there's a lot more going on in a shorter period
of time inside of a cancer cell, so they're burning a lot more energy, and they're burning
energy very inefficiently, not through the crem cycle primarily, but through the end point
of glycolysis, which is an inefficient way to make energy because the cells are that
is healthy as a normal cell.
So they need a lot of glucose, so they're gobbling up glucose.
So if you starve them for a 24 hours prior to chemotherapy, if you could think of it as
they're super hungry, they're going to uptake chemotherapy more than a healthy cell will,
and that is kind of the theory behind fasting.
Now all the research, whether they were doing 48 hours prior to chemo, fasting 24 hours,
24 hours after, or just 24 hours before, all the research showed a decrease in symptoms
by all the people that did it, a decrease in side effects of the chemotherapy, and though
you can't prove that they had better results because there's too many factors involved, I
think you get better results because the chemos get a better chance of uptaking the
cancer cells.
So of course, if it's making you sick or something like that, you have to do what is going
to be best for you, there's not a perfect number or anything like that, but I think fasting
for a period of time, however you feel comfortable fasting prior to that infusion, it's going
to be better.
What do you do when you got 48 hour period of the infusion itself, well you're probably
going to have to eat something during that time, but again, eating small amount during
that time is not going to give this giant fuel source to the cancer cells.
So you just have to do what you can do, and but I think fasting prior to the initial infusion
is going to be your best bet.
So this clinic is one doing 50 gram IV vitamin C infusions immediately after the oxaloplac.
I am always advised to have food with the IV vitamin C, which further complicates fasting
due to the IV vitamin C, also lowering blood sugars, or so I understand.
So if they're doing it right after, I mean, again, if you did the 24 hour fast, you got
the IV of the chemo, and then you're going to do the IV infusion of the vitamin C, you could
be eating while you do that, I mean, that's just one thought.